l'esprit humain est capable d'accomplir
de véritables miracles
le mentalisme c'est se connecter à
l'autre c'est écouter ce que l'autre dit
même lorsqu'il ne parle pas et nous
avons utilisé des choses rationnelles
pour créer des choses irrationnelles
comme la lecture de penser ou la
prédiction de l'avenir voilà ce qui fait
la force du spectacle mentale circus de
viktor vincent il sera sur la grande
scène du chéné rocancourt samedi 22
janvier c'est un spectacle où il ya des
démonstrations de mentalisme bien sûr
mais il ya aussi beaucoup de place mais
c'est au récit ça se passe à new york
dans les années 30 où je vais repartir
sur les traces d'artistes qui proposait
des performances mentales absolument
incroyable dans une époque elle même
incroyable et on va on va s'amuser à
revivre tout ça sur scène qu'elle
raconte est aussi l'histoire de deux de
ses personnages incroyables et c'est
dans leur histoire personnelle que qu'on
y trouve aussi de la vraie magie sur
scène beaucoup de performances
interactives un aspect important du
spectacle ce qui est amusant aussi dans
ce pays dans ce spectacle c'est que à un
moment le pouvoir entre guillemets
change de mains c'est à dire que ce sont
les personnages à les personnes qui
montent sur scène qui réalise les
exploits notamment une expérience autour
d'un calcul mental complètement fou je
prends une personne du public
et qui réalise mentalement quelque chose
créée en 2019 mentale circus mais aussi
en avant la musique très narrative venez
découvrir en famille ces fabuleuses
histoires et ces merveilleuses
expériences avec viktor vincent dans
mentale circus le mentaliste viktor
vincent sera en tournée dans toute la
france il reviendra dans les yvelines à
andrésy le vendredi 24 j'entends coeur